[Musik]
nudelboxen versprechen viele Nudeln
frisches Gemüse und extra zartes Fleisch
hinter den Riesenportionen und dem
kleinen Preis steckt allerdings ein
gewiefter Trick hier spielt die
Fleischqualität keine Rolle Sebastian
denkt out of the box und denkt auf wie
billige Zutaten Fett Profit bringen
hallo Sebastian lege hier ich würde
gerne eine Bestellung aufgeben ja ich
hätte gern einmal die gebratene Nudeln
mit Hühnerfleisch okay super bis gleich
danke tschüss
von insgesamt zehn Restaurants lässt er
sich stichproben in seine Werkstatt
liefern danke schön tschüss
[Musik]
das hier schaue ich mich jetzt mal ganz
genau an
[Musik]
das ist schwer
kleine Preise schauen wir mal aufs
Gewicht viel Mahlzeit
über ein halbes Kilo
Gemüsenudeln Fleisch
wow
[Musik]
das ist viel Sebastian lege untersucht
die nudelbox genauer und trennt die
einzelnen Zutaten Nudeln Fleisch und die
verschiedenen Gemüsesorten
[Musik]
boah ist das ölig ne das trieft ja vor
lauter Öl dann haben wir hier ein
bisschen Kohl
Zwiebeln
Möhren
die guten Sojasprossen oder mohnsprossen
und wie viel Fleisch steckt in der Asia
Box
inklusive Backteig sind das 64 Gramm
Hühnchen ein Zehntel des Gesamtgewichts
das verrät so einiges
die Untersuchung zeigt bei der teuersten
Zutat wird gespart und mit billigen
Bestandteilen aufgefüllt
die Analyse nach 10 sezierten nudelboxen
ist eindeutig
durchschnittlich stecken 10 Gramm Möhre
und elf Gramm Lauch in einer Box
außerdem 31 Gramm Sprossen und 80 g Huhn
der Rest sind Nudeln
[Musik]
350g
in jeder nudelbox ist das Fleisch es hat
eine ganz besondere weiche Konsistenz
dahinter steckt ein Trick der
Lebensmittelindustrie haben Sie sich
schon mal gewundert warum das Fleisch
immer so butterzart ist wie das feinste
Filet
hier spielt die Fleischqualität keine
Rolle der folgende Trick löst alle
Probleme
Sebastian nimmt billiges Schweinefleisch
es ist zäh und von Sehnen durchzogen die
perfekte Basis für eine günstige
asia-box
[Musik]
genau solche Plättchen braucht man dann
hat man viel Oberfläche und ist immer
eine freundliche kaugarantie das neues
Wort ist mir gerade eingefallen eine
kaugarantie immer war ich immer perfekt
jetzt werden die kleinen Fleischscheiben
chemisch behandelt
[Musik]
der Rest ist mehr als einfach
Natron das Natron zersetzt die
Oberfläche deswegen ist später
butterweich Natron kommt sonst in
Backpulver als Triebmittel zum Einsatz
weitere Zutaten Kochsalz Glutamat und
Sojasauce
[Musik]
und das Fleisch legen wir jetzt hier in
die Marinade ein ganz einfach und der
Trick funktioniert nicht nur bei
Schweinefleisch
gerade Rindfleisch ist ja mal schnell
richtig zäh das Salz Natron wird wie ein
Weichmacher außen an der fleischwand
zersetzt die Eiweiße an der Oberfläche
dadurch wird das Fleisch schön zart
[Musik]
so und schon wäre das Rind
Butter weich gemacht und wir denken woW
ist da wirklich Rinderfilet drin nein
viele asia-restaurants legen das Fleisch
über Nacht in der natronsalzmischung ein
schon ein paar Stunden reichen für einen
enormen weichmacheffekt
natron ist im Essen nicht ungefährlich
zu viel kann zu Bluthochdruck führen
oder den Wasserhaushalt stören nur in
geringen Mengen ist Natron unbedenklich
unser Fleisch ist jetzt richtig schön
durchgezogen man kann das auch sehen das
wird dann so glasig da kann man sehen
dass sie Zersetzung perfekt funktioniert
hat hier haben wir noch mal frisches
so frisches Hähnchen
behandeltes Hähnchen das sagt so ein
bisschen ein das hat nicht mehr so viel
Spannung die Eiweiß Ketten sind richtig
zersetzt und der finale Trick ist Stärke
das kann Maisstärke sein Kartoffelstärke
sein völlig egal die Stärke gibt dem
Fleisch einen Schutzfilm und hält es
saftig und macht es auch zarter so ein
bisschen übers Schweinchen ein bisschen
übers Hühnchen und ein bisschen übers
Rind
im heißen Ölbad konserviert der
stärkeschutz Willen das zart gemachte
Fleisch
wird so zum Gaumenschmaus
ahnungslose Restaurantgäste können das
nur schwer erkennen
Wahnsinn oder die Qualität des Fleisches
ist egal Pulverchen ein bisschen Stärke
und der Bus ist perfekt
abtropfen
und einmal Schweinefleisch butterweich
ob Restaurants ihr Fleisch mit Natron
behandeln steht praktisch nie auf der
Speisekarte
auch woher das Fleisch stammt bleibt im
Dunkeln
in der Gastronomie muss leider nicht
deklariert sein woher kommt das Fleisch
oder auch wie wurden die Tiere gehalten
ich habe als Verbraucher eigentlich
keine Chance mich davor zu schützen dass
da auch minderwertiges Fleisch mit
schlechten Haltungsbedingungen
drinsteckt im Supermarkt ist das
inzwischen Pflicht hier muss die
Haltungsform angegeben werden
in der Gastronomie sieht das anders aus
die Leute denken ja immer im Restaurant
da gibt es das Beste vom Besten meine
Erfahrung ist eigentlich eher wenn wir
es zum Beispiel geschafft haben dass wir
irgendein Skandal aufgedeckt haben und
dann schmeißen selbst die Discounter das
Fleisch raus dann landet es als nächstes
in der Gastronomie ich sag immer das
schwarze Loch Gastronomie wo einfach der
ganze Ramsch der industriellen
Tierhaltung reinkommt und dann halt zu
Bestpreisen als gute Ware an gutgläubige
Menschen verscherbelt wird der
Weichmacher trägt lässt auch
minderwertiges Fleisch in der billig-box
glänzen und Restaurants wird tatsächlich
ungewöhnlich günstige Ware angeboten
im Großhandel gibt es zum Beispiel diese
chicken Brest aus Thailand fix und
fertig zubereitet gekocht frittiert und
gewürzt für die nudelbox tiefgekühlt
kostet dieses Fleisch nur etwa halb so
viel wie frische Hühnerbrust im
Supermarkt
auch beim Gemüse wird gespart schnell im
Bisse setzen oft auf die günstige Ware
einige Sorten tauchen darum besonders
häufig auf
[Musik]
na komm Kohl mach mal ein bisschen mehr
der ist günstig viel Zwiebeln rein die
Kosten auch nichts
und damit wir diese Visualisierung von
Frische haben ein bisschen grün aber
mehr auch nicht
80 Prozent einer asia-box machen die
Nudeln aus sie sind bereits industriell
vorbehandelt
so Nudeln das sind quick cooking Nudeln
die muss man nur einmal kurz in Wasser
tauchen dauert eine Minute geht genauso
schnell wie das Gericht
Nudeln rein
quick cooking Nudeln werden in Asien von
großen Produzenten wie Diamond oder
Longlife hergestellt und nach
Deutschland exportiert sie bestehen aus
Weizenmehl Wasser und Salz mit oder ohne
Ei der Trick sie sind vorgekocht und
getrocknet das alles ist billig im
Großhandel kostet eine Portion
umgerechnet nur 94 Cent sie füllen fast
die ganze Box aus im Wok saugen sich die
Quick cooking Nudeln mit Flüssigkeit
voll und nehmen Gewicht auf
damit überhaupt nicht aufhören das
nächste Mal wieder an den Stand kommen
ein bisschen Glutamat jetzt fehlt nur
noch unser Hühnerfleisch und
die mungosprossen
fertig
billigste Zutaten in Sekundenschnelle
zusammengefügt
fertig ist die Asia nudelbox
die Nudeln haben alles aufgesorgt die
Sojasoße wie Fleischsäfte es sieht sehr
frisch aus durch die kleine Dose
Zuckerschoten perfekt dabei ist der
Wareneinsatz minimal die Nudeln Kosten
Sebastian 94 Cent dazu kommen Gemüse für
etwa 60 und das Fleisch für nicht einmal
50 Cent macht zusammen etwas mehr als 2
€ doch verkauft wird Sie für mindestens
das drei oder vierfache ein lohnendes
Geschäft Sebastian verkauft sie als Team
zum Freundschaftspreis
so erste Fünfer der nächste bitte
die Mogelpackung nudelbox ein echter
Kassenschlager
tja wenn sie nächstes Mal vor so einem
Stand stehen gucken sie dreimal hin was
sie bekommen und vielleicht rühren Sie
vorher mal ihre nudelbox um weil das
Fleisch liegt garantiert oben drauf
guten Appetit